[Musique]
alexis poulain bonsoir j'ai un vestiaire
bonsoir bonsoir on le disait le dossier
ukrainien qui s'invite dans la campagne
présidentielle la classe politique a
réagi à la reconnaissance de par la
russie des républiques autoproclamées du
nom bas certains critiquent la gestion
du président quand d'autres l'ont salué
à l'image de françois bayroux on va le
voir dans un tweet un pour lui le
président de la france la france résiste
sans céder d'un pas en laissant à la
porte ouverte à la paix gérard vespière
je me tourne vers vous et emmanuel
macron on l'a vu il a multiplié les
échanges diplomatiques 1 ces derniers
jours il a été au bout des choses sur
vous ah je crois et j'aurais revenir
quelques instants sur ce que vous venez
de dire le dossier ukrainien s'invite
croyez vous c'est la crise russo hier
rue social antar is l'ukrainienne pas le
dossier vous souvenez de briançon le
président vladimir poutine était reçue
par
prisa macro à brégançon ils ont parlé
uniquement pratiquement de l'ukraine
déjà 2019 voyez vous et puis il y avait
aussi l'ukraine réalisées avec volodymyr
un ski le président d'ukraine au mois de
décembre 2019 donc on est dans la
continuité mais par contre on est passés
dossier qui était le dossier à l'époque
à une crise à une tension et c'est ça
qui fait la différence le président
emmanuel macron il est critiqué par
l'opposition cette période électorale
pour vous il était au bout des choses il
a bien fait les choses le président
français moi je crois qu'il y avait
trois casquettes n'est ce pas il avait
le la présidence de l'union européenne
il avait la responsabilité d'un pays qui
est il a la responsabilité un pays
qu'ils la seule puissance nucléaire sur
le continent à part la russie
l'angleterre est légèrement détaché et
troisièmement les présidents des pays
membres du conseil de sécurité donc au
nom de ses trois niveaux de
responsabilité je crois qu'il étape il a
fait le voyage à à moscou et a pris le
téléphone il a rencontré à beaucoup de
responsables
occidentaux allemand particulier donc je
crois que oui il est allé au bout des
possibilités mais ce n'est pas lui qui
conduit les chars n'est ce pas donc à
ali à l'évidence la russie a eu les
initiatives militaires et donc devant
des initiatives militaires bien il faut
prendre des décisions et prendre ses
responsabilités alexis poulain la
posture des manuels macron sur cette
crise ukrainienne alors qu'on est en
pleine campagne présidentielle comment
est-ce que vous l'observez et
malheureusement on aurait pu croire à
des avancées diplomatiques
après sa visite en russie d'ailleurs il
n'a pas arrêté d'être téléphone deux
fois puis trois fois annonçant même
dimanche à un sommet qu'il aurait obtenu
de haute lutte entre l'admirent poutine
et joe biden qui n'a pas eu lieu
évidemment donc on voit qu'il ya comme
d'habitude avec hélène macro beaucoup de
blabla beaucoup de communication et très
peu de rendu donc c'est une façon de se
positionner en tant que leader au dessus
de la mêlée on voit bien que il retarde
encore davantage sa déclaration de
candidature qui devait avoir lieu la
semaine prochaine ou la semaine du 28
février nous disent et on dans les
cercles macro nist donc là clairement
cette crise internationale lui donne une
stature internationale qui les seuls à
pouvoir avoir puisqu'il est chef des
armées qu'il est président de la
république et donc il va être au dessus
finalement de ces débats de la
présidentielle qui vont paraître anodin
par rapport à une crise internationale
ou lui va se donner le beau rôle donc
c'est une façon d'enjamber encore ses
élections qu'ils voyaient déjà comme
quelque chose qu'ils n'avaient pas à
faire pas de débat avec les autres
candidats et puis un bilan qu'il ne veut
absolument pas défendre parce que c'est
difficilement défendable sur beaucoup de
point g inverse pires qu au fond comme
l'expliquent alexis poulain vous trouvez
vous aussi que emmanuel macron se sert
finalement de cette séquence
diplomatique internationale de cette de
cette crise pour sa campagne électorale
vous savez on peut se servir de quelque
chose quand on à l'initiative de cette
chose là mais quand on n'a pas
l'initiative
on obligé de répondre quand vous c'est
pas vous qui lançait la balle est obligé
de renvoyer la balle donc c'est très
facile de d'exprimer need et on disant
bon voilà il est au dessus des choses
bien sûr mais il n'a pas eu la volonté
d'ouvrir le dossier où la crise
ukrainienne espace la crise daniel
s'impose dans le calendrier et il est à
même de prendre ses responsabilités pour
avoir les dialogues nécessaires pour
éviter
effectivement que le conflit ne dégénère
en une potentielle guerre et je crois
que si on arrive à éviter cela ce sera
une des contributions du président
emmanuel match finalement alexis point
il n'a pas une fois emmanuel macron
cette crise et leur arrivée à son terme
seulement bien sûr il n'a pas le choix
mais après se mettre en scène dans les
photos de soizic la manière comme il le
fait ça c'est un choix de mise en scène
c'est encore un choix d'influenceurs a
un moment faut que mails macro arrêt tik
tok qui fasse de la vraie diplomatie or
avoir ce genre de mise en scène c'est
vraiment volontaire et là on est dans la
campagne me faites pas croire que ces
photos là sont nécessaires pour résoudre
la crise on est en france donc on a
l'impression que emmanuel macron a un
rôle extrêmement important dans cette
crise ukrainienne or on voit bien que
côté russe poutine ne souhaite parler
cabaye donne parce qu'il sait que les
européens sont faibles yannick jadot
parler d'une europe forte aujourd'hui
l'europe diplomatiquement n'existe pas
ou très peu cet ensemble de pays
globalement alignée sur la position
américaine avec le temps évidemment et
puis n'oublions pas cette crise
ukrainienne au delà des territoires
c'est l'histoire de nord stream ii c'est
l'histoire du gaz c'est l'histoire aussi
des américains qui souhaitent ne pas
voir leurs protégés l'allemagne dépendre
trop des russes et puis prendre prendre
leurs ailes donc on a vraiment derrière
toute la mécanique otanesque qui se met
en place on a à la fois deux
superpuissances qui se parlent et
l'europe au milieu qui essaye d'avoir un
rôle mais c'est pas le rôle titre c'est
plutôt un deuxième rôle en tout cas tous
les candidats ont réagi tous les
candidats à la présidentielle il ya
ségolène royal aussi qui a fait un tweet
est pour elle et aucun candidat n'est à
la hauteur des enjeux regardez il nous
faudrait un nouveau général de gaulle
qui se faisait respecter de nos amis
américains en leur disant de retirer
leurs troupes la russie n'a t'elle pas
droit au respect des accords sur la
sécurité à ses frontières les sanctions
économiques pénalise bien plus l'europe
finalement ségolène royal qui cite le
général de gaulle et on comprend voilà
que personne n'a la stature aujourd'hui
en france selon elle pour régler ce type
de de crise c'est le cas jara vestiaire
vous le dire même pas elle je crois
qu'effectivement elle n'a pas la stature
non plus donc il faut être très très
prudent parce que la sortie du
commandement intégré de l'otan selon les
termes précis de l'époque en 1966
n'était pas une sortie de l'otan une
sortie du commandement intégré donc on
en restait toujours avec la protection
nucléaire américaine et donc en ce qui
concerne le rôle de l'europe qui est
évoqué tout à l'heure n'oublions pas que
les 425 millions de citoyens libres et
démocrates à qui abrite donc en europe
qui a représenté l'union européenne et
est bien c'est la deuxième puissance
économique du monde n'est ce pas donc il
y a une capacité à intervenir sur les
affaires du monde parce que
effectivement
là l'allemagne a besoin de gaz elle a
besoin potentiellement du gaz russe mais
les russes ont aussi besoin de vendre
leur gaz donc clients et fournisseurs se
tiennent réciproquement et quand vous
regardez la situation économique russe à
10 % d'inflation quand vous regardez le
taux de la banque centrale russe à neuf
et demi pour cent n'est ce pas personne
n'en parle alors effet les les 135 mille
soldats à la frontière sont en très très
bon par avance un camouflage de la
situation économique russe
dispose inflation 9% de la banque
centrale 600 morts par jour duco vide
depuis le 28 juin et la personne n'en
parle cette crise protège aussi la
vision que nous devons avoir européen de
la réalité russe il y à une puissante
armée mais il y a une économie très
difficile on va revenir sur le contexte
1 2 de la présidentielle alexis certains
appels à des sanctions d'autres plus
mesurés rejettent cette solution il
appelle à de nouveaux traités sur les
frontières est ce que la position des
uns des autres finalement elle va avoir
un impact sur le choix des électeurs est
ce que elle est importante à ce moment
là à quelques mois du premier tour je
crois qu'aujourd'hui se joue une
question sur le la vision européenne en
fait est ce que la france doit s'aligner
ce qu'on doit aller vers davantage
d'intégration européenne ou est-ce qu'on
doit être un pays souverain et dans ce
cas-là tenir tête aux états unis mais
comme russe c'est à dire être non
alignés d'un côté comme de l'autre et
pouvoir avoir une voix or aujourd'hui on
voit que la commission d'ursula von der
leyen ou même bruxelles est totalement
alignée sur la position américaine donc
parler d'europe forte c'est simplement
parlé d'une dilution de la souveraineté
française donc ce qui va se passer avec
les prises de parole des candidats c'est
un axe souverainiste contre un axe
européen
globaliste on va dire où et c'est
quelque chose qui existe déjà ça va
simplement forcé le trait je pense et
puis après il ya la question bien sûr de
pied à la hauteur qui peut avoir aussi
une vision un peu régaliennes qui
pourraient se projeter dans le rôle du
chef ou de la chef des armées puisqu'on
parle de guerre et pas et d'une rigueur
un pas celle de la guerre ducobu de
rappelez vous la déclaration des malades
mâcon nous sommes en guerre bon on voit
hollandais est d'ailleurs parlé de
l'inflation mais l'inflation aux
etats-unis elle est terrible aussi la
fed est en train justement maintenant de
pointer le doigt sur deux nuls vous avez
des taux sur les taux de la fed qui vont
remonter ou sur l'inflation des deux
jeux 2d sur l'inflation je n'ai pas les
chiffres et je crois que c'était du 5%
si vous voulez les chiffres mais mais ce
qui était drôle c'était de voir joe
biden qui accusait la crise ukrainienne
pour l'inflation américaine bon on peut
toujours continuer comme ça et la dette
alors par contre je savais rien de vrai
dans le tram et le milliard de dollars
dès la première parce qu'il y avait
sûrement une prime n'a peu près
115 dollars le baril sur le prix du
baril actuel lié à la tension jeu
politique donc cette hausse des
carburants systra d'une morosité des
consommateurs
effectivement intervient directement
dans l'inflation et dieu sait si a été
le nom les ménages français sont
sensibles à au prix du plein à la pompe
et scellier en particulier est vraiment
fortement à la tension géopolitique en
tout cas est-ce que c'est effectivement
ce que disait alexis poulain selon vous
un axe souverainiste contre euro pays ce
qui est en train de se décider c'est là
où où les candidats sont la possibilité
de se démarquer finalement avant la
présidentielle alors c'est moi je suis
politicien donc je me méfie des idées et
j'essaye de regarder les chiffres et les
réalités et les fêtes et quand il y à
144 145 millions de russes en face nous
à côté de nous devons nous bon comment
comment répondre à la ligne à 67
millions de francs c'est bon c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose donc avec 82
millions de dhs allemand là on commence
à être 150 millions ensemble de franco
allemand par rapport à 144 millions
d'euros on peut commencer à parler donc
si on est de plus en plus nombreux
autour de la table n'est ce pas eh bien
on peut faire face à une discussion et
on retrouve ce même parallèle vis-à-vis
des affaires militaires quand vous avez
un pays la russie qui disposent de mille
cinq cents ogives et bien nous français
nous n'avons 250 et déployer cette
disproportion là donc il y as besoin si
vous voulez parler d'égal à égal avec
moscou avec la russie eh bien il faut
être plus large que nous le sommes nous
même autrement ça ne fonctionne pas ça
fonctionnera jamais dans ce cas là avec
la chine par exemple personne peut
gagner face à la chine avec une telle
logique bien sûr que si comment j'ai
bien parce qu'il sait le l'union de
démocratie qui prouve à six qui fera
vaciller la chine et on reparlera avant
la fin de la décennie on en reparlera
sur l'économie chinoise
on en reparlera sur la démographie
chinoise là chine va au devant de très
gros problèmes il s'agira d'être très
attentif à ce dossier on en reparlera
ensemble dossiers alexis poulain pour
conclure mais cette crise va se dérouler
dans les jours qui viennent on voit que
l'angle pris par les démocraties
occidentales c'est les sanctions
sanctions qui vont toucher les
oligarques et certaines personnalités
les élus et autres donc l'idée c'est de
ne pas faire souffrir le peuple russe
non plus de ne pas aller du côté
irréversible de continuer d'une certaine
façon la diplomatie pour éviter une
escalade même si de l'autre côté canada
grande bretagne etats unis envoient des
armes létales --allemagne france envoie
des armes non létales pour essayer de
supporter les ukrainiens en cas
d'attaqué plus poussée au delà des
territoires donc on voit que cette crise
tout est sur la table est derrière elle
se résoudra par le par le commerce
simplement dire à un moment quel est
l'intérêt d'une guerre aujourd'hui pour
les parties en présence merci à tous les
deux d'avoir accepté d'être sur le
plateau berthet france ce soir merci
alexis poulain éditorialistes arte
france merci j'ai un vestiaire
fondateurs du web magazine le monde a
décrypté le savoir